I'll show is look around you and it's a
what is it it's kind of like 10 8 10
minute comedy shorts which are spoofing
science education programs that we were
forced to watch when we were kids at
school yeah sounds hilarious without
calcium man would be unable to process
food and would starve everything you say
is just nonsense basically we didn't we
started at first we thought we should
read up and then we fall no let's not
look at any books and just make yourself
so without any research we were
traumatized by science and education I
think both of us were oh I'm talking in
this Yoda speak I think education both
of us were traumatized by we have one
whole episode about ghosts where it's
like the thing is you know as we all
know ghosts exist and you know you've
probably seen a ghost in your life you
know we do experiments with ghosts and
you know and it's all treated very
matter-of-factly you know when we have
an experiment where we go into the
haunted laboratory where the scientist
works hand in hand with a ghost
scientist who's just invisible who's
quite naughty isn't it it's sort of like
a poltergeist it kind of goes wrong and
there's some ectoplasm
sometimes when ghosts which you eat
materialized to some explosion which I
eat and it tastes like pigs milk
anyway that's some of the some of the
highlights from the pilk yes it's
delightful
it says no iron is or to give it its
full name iron to havilland we do an
experiment in which we feed an electric
current through what do we through an
iron pyramid which causes a spot to go
through the ceiling and put a hole
through the ceiling of the lab which
we've never been outside and we go
outside and see what's happened and you
see the laboratory for the first time
and in the sky is a giant pair of
scissors floating there
and then a register says this is an old
experiment that you've probably seen
before but well worth trying under less
than just the scissors slowly fade
there's also an iron where there's a
girl it's like there's a it's like a
hobby you've probably seen people who
collect iron filings you know and we see
a little girl about six they put the
iron filings and in the background
there's a filing cabinet that says I am
filing cabinet that's such a police
squad it's made of iron anyways so
that's it's a bit like two and a Half
Men
in a nutshell yeah with iron filings
there's lots of commentaries this we
spent so long run the features for this
DVD yeah we got tim and eric' such
horrible guys think we're now really
funny Johnny Steele did they steal
something they must have been to play
with them and I just hate when Eric gets
into a rage you know he's got the
strength of five men he goes mad yeah
five little men by little five men on
the less Matt and Trey from South Park
yeah which is amazing who are heroes of
ours we were going to do a film about
Henry the eighth and just write it
without doing any research at all just
just not knowing anything about it's
just he's just knowing this or just
knowing this sort of vibe of Henry the
eighth and that's that's all the
research and just Henry the eighth have
you know who thought actually was the
only attractive part of them you know no
way we are being truthful one of us is
being truthful and the other one always
lies